[Music]
the world's largest orchid grows several
meters tall the tiniest is practically
invisible
some blue high up in trees while others
live underground all in there are around
28,000 species of orchid on earth about
as many as all the bird mammal and
reptile species combined they grow all
over the world baring every imaginable
color shape and pattern and there's a
cunning purpose behind these elaborate
displays many orchids trick insects
sometimes even into having sex with them
like other flowers most orchids need to
attract insects to gather their pollen
and carry it between plants but unlike
most flowers which attract a range of
pollinators with sweet nectar these
Masters of Deception deploy other
tactics like pretending to be in insects
mate letting off alluring sense and
mimicking the appearance of other
species one of their most intriguing
methods is sexual deception through a
combination of sexy shapes and
pheromones orchids convince insects to
mate with them take the bee orchid whose
petals look almost exactly like the
velvety body of a bee this disguise is
so convincing that male bees land on the
orchid and try to have sex with it
picking up pollen as they go other
orchids have evolved contrasting colors
and ultraviolet spots invisible to
humans but irresistible to insects still
others have tactile love handles that
ensure insects are positioned precisely
for pollination when a male wasp lands
on the hammer' orchid for example his
enthusiastic mating motion
it's a hinge in the flour forcing his
body into the pollen at the next flower
he visit that same hinge pushes his
pollen covered body onto the stigma
fertilizing it some orchids make such
convincing mate that insects even
ejaculate on wasting valuable sperm but
the most vital component of sexual
deception is sent orchids mimic the
precise scent of a single insect species
this is possible because many insects
and flowers produce simple organic
compounds called hydrocarbons which form
a layer that protects their bodies from
drying out
the precise blend of compounds in this
layer is species specific its scent can
double as a way for insects to attract
potential mates known as a sex pheromone
over the course of many thousands of
years random compound combinations have
given some orchid species precisely the
same signature scent as particular
insect species this matching scent
allows them to attract male pollinators
who fall over and over again for the
flowers masquerading as females of their
own species sexual deception isn't the
only trick orchids have up their sleeves
their oldest scam is mimicking the
shapes and colors of other nectar
producing flowers but without the sweet
nectar some orchids also masquerade as
places where insects lay their eggs one
species not only has the color and
appearance of rotting meat
it emits a scent of decay as well
drawing in flies who deposit their eggs
on the flower and unwittingly pollinate
the plant other orchids look and smell
just like the fungi on which certain
insects lay there
where do all these bizarre adaptations
come from random genetic mutations in
orchids may result in a trait like a
scent or shape that by chance matches
the needs of a single insect species the
huge diversity within the insect world
also increases the likelihood that an
orchid will find a unique audience able
to make more seeds and offspring with
the help of its dedicated pollinators
the orchid successfully reproduces in
isolation and becomes a new species but
because of their dependence on sometimes
just one pollinator species orchids are
also vulnerable and many quickly go
extinct over time though more orchid
species have formed than died out and
orchids are some of the most diverse
flowering plants they have such
exuberant and otherworldly shapes that
they occasionally deceive human senses
to in their petals we see what appear to
be tiny dancing people monkeys faces
spiders and even birds in flight when it
comes to evolution it's not always all
about attraction sometimes it's about
defense
check out this lesson to learn about the
amazing adaptations plants use to ward
off predators
[Music]